[Musique]
la princesse l'a dit nîmes ou qu en
espagne est toujours la proie facile du
toréador lolo qui exerce sur elle une
dictature puissante et viril alors
nadine amouk qu'est ce que tu penses de
la dernière mode espagnole c'est une
ravissante revêt l'habit sans amis sont
là dix ans bon eh bien il veut préparer
mon prochain corrida attendant tu va
répéter avec moi les commandements de la
femme du torero primero il n'y aura pas
d'autres hommes dans ma vie et mon mari
les taux les rouleaux bien secundo n'en
fait pas trop deuxièmement je
respecterai toujours à bellmer haye
était au travail et même en avant
d'accomplir mon devoir conjugal
j'ai récupéré 50 pater et 50 av je ferai
50 fois moins devoir conjugal avant de
réciter un master et de passer à 100
caractères j'ai mangé là il veut que tu
connaisses tous à part quand il revient
matusz a mal on m'a encore un bon mais
qu'est-ce qui me contre 7 familles sont
plus qu une fringue et tout
najim ebooks dîner qu'elle pas l'air de
te revoir
qu'est ce que tu fais là genoux comme ça
en espagne je te mets sur un tour
adorent ils n'arrêtent pas de le réciter
des masters et des papes du munster
mais c'est pour ça que je suis venu par
l'odeur alléché la loupe les locaux même
poule pourquoi ces jaloux un bout à
toulouse où les montres betino de
schwarz vous donnent leurs à la seconde
près il est 18 heures 22 minutes 30
secondes
habituez-vous aux nouvelles télévisions
bientôt tous les programmes seront
entrecoupées par des publicités et
maintenant qu'il ya un amoureux du sumo
et avec ce qu'ils m'ont fait baver plus
on met deux mois moi je veux plus rester
ici mais les jaloux c'est lui car ils
ont tiré en train d'être interrogés la
tuer way enlève ça va
madre oui la vie auquel viennent
partenaires et qu'une autre en six mois
ci si tu finis bungie les oreilles et la
queue et google qui veut jouer les
mamans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bobby non
[Musique]